what is up boys and girls Jerry o Terry
here live from New York it's
Tuesday afternoon and I here with
another First Impressions video for you
check it out late last night Ryan and I
went to the cinema we went to the movies
to see a film that that I wasn't so sure
we were going to see that y'all have
been itching to hear about and uh I'm
going to level with you right up front I
was not excited to see this mov movie I
I didn't really want to go I even texted
R I was like selfishly I would not like
to pay top dollar to see this in the
evening I'd rather go to a cheap Mata or
something like that and the movie of
course that I talking about forgive me
is Ninja Turtles Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles the 2014 reboot of the you know
classic thing from childhood that you
love you know I'm not a Turtles expert
all right I'm I'm going to be upfront
about that I'm not an expert but I did
grow up with the turtles you know we had
the movie you know uh the the liveaction
film we had the cartoons some we had the
action figures we had some of the video
games so the turtles were around all
right I played with the turtles as a
child um at least a little bit I'm not
sitting here being like ah this is my
life but you know I I like the Ninja
Turtles you know I'm down so um when I
heard about this
movie um I wasn't really thinking about
it one way or the other I mean everyone
freaked out over this um partly simply
because of Michael Bay everybody hates
Michael Bay nowadays and and I
understand completely uh I feel like he
is an easy target but but most people
freaked out because ah Michael ba is
going to ruin the Ninja Turtles and I
think that's the first thing we need to
address this is not a Michael Bay movie
Michael Bay's company produced this is a
platinum Dunes production uh Platinum
Dunes who you may know uh they do a lot
of horror movie remakes they remade the
Texas Chainsaw Massacre uh Friday the
13th Nightmare on Elm Street the
Amityville Horror The Hitcher stuff like
that um and lately they've been
branching out into more original
territory with the purge movies uh and
at least slightly different reboot
territory with this movie so yeah
Michael Bay did a lot of the talking for
this partly because Michael Bay of all
the guys involved with Platinum Dunes is
the biggest household name if you're a
horror fan you might know the name Brad
Fuller um Brad Fuller and Andrew form
are the other guys who uh are involved
the Platinum dudes and I get the sense
that they are the ones who do the
day-to-day stuff over there cuz let's
face it Michael ba is busy he's making
his own movies he's directing stuff he's
looking at lingerie models you know he's
doing whatever Michael baay is doing um
so I get the sense that while he does
you know oversees things I get the sense
of the other guys are the more
day-to-day people but you're making
Ninja Turtles Michael B God talk about
it cuz he's the big guy so this is not a
Michael Bay film uh which is very
apparent when you watch it because a a
you can see what's going on and B it's
an hour and 40 minutes long it's not
nearly 3 hours which is great so um also
I don't know like Michael B must slather
his actors in glycerin or something like
that because it was so refreshing to not
have everybody like in a perfectly
glamorous and golden sweat all the time
it was just neat uh this film is
directed by a guy who you might know he
did a Texas cha Massacre the Beginning
for platinum Dunes a while ago he did um
battle Los Angeles which I actually
caught on TV a while later and it's a
pretty effective movie I mean it's not
great but but it does its job well
enough um and uh he did Wrath of the
Titans and stuff like that so this film
how does it work out how does it Stack
Up is Michael Bay's company [__] on
our childhoods and you know what I'm
going to say not really I'm going to
level with you I had fun with this you
know
what it's not that bad it's really not
it's not that good either but it's also
not that bad for everyone who's freaking
out over this um I think a lot of that
Panic is a little unfounded it's it's an
okayish movie and it does get some stuff
right I had fun when I should have been
having fun and I also had fun when I
probably shouldn't have been having fun
which isn't isn't to the movie's credit
but look what's the most important part
of indent Turtles movie the Ninja
Turtles themselves Shredder and Master
Splinter how are those things those are
the best things about this movie and
that in and of itself is good you know
it's like if you're going to walk out of
a Ninja Turtles movie thinking yeah the
best stuff is probably the Turtle stuff
and the stuff with shredder and Splinter
they at least did something right I mean
this movie centers around April O'Neal
you know she's she wants to be a serious
journalist you know she wants to be a
real reporter but she's doing all these
fluff pieces so she's out on her own
trying to shed some light on this Foot
Clan Action uh getting her nose into all
sorts of places it doesn't belong and
then she sort of stumbles upon the
turtles uh because of that and you know
Megan Fox again everyone hates Megan Fox
she does a fine job I mean she she she's
good she's fine she does a good job it's
fine it's really fine um will arette is
in this playing April O'Neal's
cameraman uh who is like
the most tall handsome well-groomed
charismatic humorous Charming cameraman
you've ever seen in your life he's a lot
of fun I really liked Will Arnett and
William ficner who who you've seen in a
lot of things he is in this he does a
great job um you know he turns in a good
performance and when the movie does
inevitably ratchet up into more
ridiculous territory he follows suit in
in what I thought was actually a pretty
nice way so the cast is is pretty good
and the guys who voiced the turtles
Johnny Knoxville and and some other
folks they also do a good job their
camaraderie is really fun you know they
seem even though they're CG the guys
seem to play off each other really well
and each of the Turtles has a
personality just like they did in all
the comics and the shows and stuff
donatell is the more sort of nerdy
technical guy and then Michelangelo is
obviously like the dude you know and uh
a little more a little more modern on
that a little more um hipop culture
influence
um and then Leonardo's the leader and
Raphael is the troubled you know Rebel
and they have a nice little family unit
uh you know sort of put together with uh
you know Master Splinter and all that
who is voiced by Tony shaloo so you know
you you get all the necessary stuff and
the tone overall I know a lot of people
say the movie takes itself too seriously
and when the trailer came out I it
certainly seemed that way cuz you know
again I wasn't very excited about this
movie going in and the trailer didn't
help me get excited because the trailer
looked like every other trailer I've
ever seen for a movie like this the
trailer made it look like this was going
to be a super serious movie and it for
the most part does know how to have fun
and it's not like a Transformers movie
in the sense that it takes a break every
now and again and shoehorns humor in
there's a lot of humor that comes
naturally from the characters and stuff
like that so you know it's not high art
but it's it's fun you know um and even
when it's not about the turtles you know
it's like the thing about this movie is
that I get the sense that they paid the
most attention script wise to the
Turtles
Story which is good um but everything
else kind of doesn't get paid attention
it's like there's a lot of really
horrible logic or just really sort of
glaring flaws in the
plot there are a lot of moments where
you're like you have this thing why
didn't you show it to these people like
or why are the Foot Clan just never
around until you're trying to get to the
next loc like the Foot Clan in this
movie is a pretty ineffective
organization except for Shredder who's
really scary like Shredder is really
well done um you know at first I was
like oh here we go and then he put that
suit on and got blades everywhere and
and he was a formidable villain I was
like how are they going to defeat this
guy and the action and the effects and
stuff like that when it comes to the
actual fights is really good um so like
it's competent for all the reasons you
want it to be and it's all the
connective tissue that sort of pales by
comparison but it becomes and I I hate
to say this but it becomes sort of goofy
after a while with all the sort
of this sort of dumb logic or or like
glaring omissions in logic it's still
fun because you're sort of throwing your
hands up being like what is going on
like the plot is pretty simple it's not
that the plot's hard to follow or
anything like that or the plot in of
itself is dumb but you know there's just
a lot of stuff in there where you're
like really you you didn't have a really
there like there are a lot of really
weird decisions that characters make
that seem to only serve the plot
something about the characters is like
characters will make decisions that are
so sort of illogical and dumb at times
where I can't even blame the characters
anymore I can't even call the characters
stupid because it's so screamingly
obvious that it's a bad script decision
you know so it's like scene where where
April O'Neal decides not to show the
photographic evidence to her boss only
to show it to someone else in the next
scene is a little ridiculous again you
know I know I freaked out on
Transformers 4 for being so damn long
but I really think that that helps it's
like I feel like Michael Bay could oddly
enough take a couple notes from this
movie
because it's not hyper gratuitous in a
lot of the ways Michael Bay movie movies
are and it also doesn't outstay it's
welcome like an hour 40 minutes is just
fine for this kind of movie you get
enough of the oh these bad guys are bad
and you get enough of the fun stuff and
you get enough of the action and it's
not overwrought you know it's fine like
and that's what also I guess makes it
that much less
offensive in certain in a certain way is
like it's not going to sit around for 3
hours pretending to be more important
than it
is it's an hour and a half hour and 40
minutes and then you're done you know
it's fun and I get the sense that they
knew that so that's good could the film
have been better yeah I mean are there
simple ways in which it could have been
better yeah it's like if they had just
taken a couple more passes that that
script but you know be that as it may
it's never non entertaining it never
really drags um and when there's action
there's action you know there's a really
cool opening sequence that's like
animation you know know that sort of
looks like the old comics and stuff like
that so that's neat you know for what it
is you know it it's a good time how is
it as a movie it's fun it's definitely
fun it's it's it's and that sort of
helped to even out the tone for me is
like it was fun when it wanted to be and
when it was trying to be more serious it
was a little bit goofy but hey I was
still having fun so you know maybe it
was just because I had low expectations
or I was tired of all the you know
people freaking out over it but you know
it's an all right movie you catch it at
a mattina or you watch it at home even
you're going to have a good time I think
if you're open to it you know it's
definitely I don't think it's [__]
on anybody's childhood really it's it's
fine it's a fine it's fine it's it's
fine guys it'll be okay um so yeah Ninja
Turtles Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
2014 um yeah fun fun
fun uh so yeah I guess they're they're
already going to do the second one what
would you guys like to see what's your
jam you know they've done Shredder I
know a lot of people are like be Bopp
and rock steady uh so what do you want
to see in another Ninja Turtles movie um
let's talk about that so uh yeah comment
like follow us on Twitter and stuff and
uh until next time until this weekend or
whatever I am Jerry the movie is Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles and uh
cheers